a Clockwork Orange based on Anthony
Burgess's novel of the same name is one
of the best and most controversial
movies of the 1970s despite the
arguments surrounding the film's
violence this Stanley Kubrick picture
has become an iconic piece of pop
culture and multiple directors and
showrunners have since paid tribute to
it in their own works so pour yourself a
glass of milk as we delve into some of
our favorite clockwork orange' Easter
eggs Hellraiser
directed by horror icon Clive Barker
Hellraiser is a horror classic that gave
the world pinhead
one of the all-time great movie monsters
the film also contains a Clockwork
Orange reference that's so quick that
it's easy to miss in the pick the cotton
house is located at 55 Ludovico Place
which is a reference to the infamous
torture technique that Alex experiences
in Kubrick's masterpiece well that's
good I like to pity the old films now
and again Trainspotting like a Clockwork
Orange Trainspotting is also a
masterclass of British cinema and it
includes quite a few nods - Kubrick's
tour de force not only did Danny Boyle
design the film's volcano nightclub to
look reminiscent of clockwork score of a
milk bar with all the writing on the
wall but the background music was played
by heaven 17 a band that was named after
a fictional pop group from the Anthony
Burgess novel Star Trek The Next
Generation in the fourth season of Star
Trek The Next Generation an episode
called the mind's eye featured the
Romulans using their own version of the
Ludovico technique since Geordi LaForge
is blind they have to pump images of
violence straight into his brain which
is somehow even creepier than what
happens to Alex and clockwork it can
tell you've gone to a lot of trouble
deed we have the dark night while Heath
Ledger was playing the Joker in the Dark
Knight he kept a creepy journal of all
of his influences and thoughts to
prepare for the production it's probably
not too surprising that Alex DeLarge was
a source of inspiration for Heath
Ledger's performance as the Joker
because they're both sadistic
Psychopaths who want to see the world
burn
hello beautiful but what might come as a
shock is how we managed to sneak in a
subtle nod to clockwork and its director
in his own version of the Kubrick's tear
the Kubrick's tear is a nod to the fact
that at some point in nearly all of his
movies the director has one of the
characters stare at the camera with
their head tilted down looking up from
under the eyebrows with a crazed look in
their eyes it shows up quite often in
clockwork
so it's probably no coincidence that
after being so influenced by Alex
DeLarge ledger borrowed that iconic
piece of Malcolm McDowell's performance
as well team Titans a recurring villain
in the DC Universe mad mod is an
eccentric fashion designer who uses
style and technology to brainwash and
wreak havoc in the animated series from
2003 in the revival in 2017 the
character was voiced by none other than
Malcolm McDowell himself to celebrate
his involvement the show goes full bore
on a Clockwork Orange Easter eggs during
his guest stints mad mad forces the Teen
Titans to watch mind-control videos and
then he also appears alongside a ton of
weird psychedelic imagery it wouldn't
look out of place in the movie that made
him famous kana those nasty superpowers
disrupting my lecture napkin I American
Gods the first episode of American Gods
gave us all the great characters and
bloody mayhem that we've come to expect
from TV producer Brian fuller one thing
fans really liked was the design of the
technical boy in his minions the
children perhaps the reason they were so
popular was that they were familiar to
clockwork fans as a nod of the droogs
just like the droogs the children were
two-tone jumpsuits and enjoy being
silent and violent that's a new way
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Applause]
[Music]